ودعا كل من يستطيع حمل السلاح للقتال ضد
من وصفهم بالمتمردين كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا
ولنا في نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما دلاله دعوه
البرهان المواطنين للانخراط في القتال ضد
الدعم السريع ما هي المتغيرات التي يمكن
ان تترتب على هذه الدعوه على الصراع بين
الجيش والدعم السريع فما هي المسارات التي
يمكن ان تاخذها الاوضاع في السودان في ظل
تصاعدي حده الصراع
ان حجم المؤامره يتطلب من الجميع ان يغيظ
والاستعداد للتصدي للمهددات الوجوديه
لدولتنا لذلك نطلب من جميع شباب بلادي وكل
من يستطيع الدفاع ان لا يتردد او يتاخر
بان يقوم بهذا الدور الوطني في مكان سكنه
او بالانضمام للحراسه العسكريه لهذه
الدعوه التي يعني قدمها رئيس مجلس السياده
وقائد الجيشيه اعتراف صريح منه بالفشل
العسكري وكذلك الفشل السياسي من جعل هذه
المعركه من كونها معركه للقوات المسلحه من
اجل انهاء ما اعتبره تمرد الى الهروب
للامام ومحاوله اعتبار هذه معركه وجوديه
وهذا كله لا يتفق الواقع وهذا الطريق هو
طريق الحرب الاهليه ان تجعل السلاح في يد
كل من يستطيع حمل سلاح الجيش ذكر مرارا
وتكرارا انه ان يده مغلوله لانه لا يستطيع
ان يهاجم قوات الدعم السريع في المنازل هم
يحتمون بالمنازل يحتمون بالمستشفيات
يحتمون بالجامعات وبالمدارس وبالكنائس حتى
اعلامي بمحاوله اداره الموقف وارسال رسائل
في بريد الجميع بعد البرهان هو ماذا
ليسيطر على مقاليد الامور العسكريه وكذلك
السياسيه فضلا عن ذلك عندما اشار الى ان
هنالك مؤامره كان ينبغي ان يتحدث بشكل
مباشر وبالشكل صريح وان يقوم باجراءات
دبلوماسيه بما في ذلك قطع العلاقات ما هذه
الدول التي تدير المؤامره
[موسيقى]
جدا
هذا اعلان صريح من البرهان بالتخلي عن
مسؤولياته كقائد للجيش
واعلان فشله في قياده اي عمليه عسكريه هذه
ليست حظ ضد البرهان وليست حرض ضد الجيش
هذه حرب ضد الشعب السوداني المجموعات التي
لهذه الخطوه مجموعات معلومه اتبع تتبع
للنظام المطور الوطني هذه الحرب حدث
استطاق كل طرف او يحاول ان يدافع في الطرف
الذي يرى من خلال تحقيق مصالحه وكذلك
مكاسبه الشخصيه
يعني الدعم السريع يرحب بالمبادرات كلها
وشارك بفعاليه في منبر جده لكن الطرف الذي
يمانع دائما من التفاوض ويرى بان التفاوض
ينبغي ان يكون حول القضاء الانسانيه وانه
ماض في خطته للقضاء او على الانهاء ما
يعتبره تمرد هو الجيش وبالتالي ليس لديه
ما يمكن ان ينفذ به هذه الخطه خطط انهاء
التمرد الحرب الدعم السريع لم تقتصر على
الجيش بل توجهت في الاساس الى المواطنين
بالاستيلاء على المنازل احتلال الاحياء
السكنيه النهب والسلب مع مرور الايام اتضح
ان هذا الامر هو مشكل مؤامره تشارك فيها
اطراف دوليه واقليميه تستهدف اختطاف
الدوله السودانيه واجراء تغيير ديموغرافي
كبير فيها
ينبغي ان تكون هنالك ادوار فاعله
وادوار استطيع ان اقول انها حاسمه لليمين
مرضيه التفاوض وهذا المنبر في تقديره
هنالك بعض العيوب اذا استطاع ان يعالجها
كقضيه توفير مقرات لاخوات الدعم السريعه
المنتظره في الاحياء وكذلك في المستشفيات
الى مناطق فضلا عن ذلك ان تكون هنالك خطه
سريعه لدمج عناصر الدعم السريع في القوات
المسلحه